سلام خ
شل اويلي شلون اللعبه شلون راح تب حسنين
وين حسنين ما يلا
خلدي
زيون
برامج ماك مكان
اروح
دو طارق
طارق
حس والله دير
بالك حس احنا
وينوم شك لعنا وصنا جو التلفزيون يا لعنه
هاي لعن ب راح يطلع زين التلفزيون يا
تلفزيون
اتحمله
اهلا فيكم اعزائي المشاهدين في البرنامج
العربي معكم حسين الاغ وبرنامج صد
المطاعم مرحبا بك طارق اهلا وسهلا ضيف
طارق المهضوم التخين
شويه
طارق عن
اول
كان كروش على مر التاريخ هذا الكتاب
قرايته انت اكثر من 200 مره الكتاب ن
اعجابي هذا كتاب ترى نفسك عظاما في الجدر
المنفرد ارى نفسي وحيدا في الجدر يطربك
يطربك الشيف رمزي الشيف رمزي من اروع صراع
العمبه صاص في الثلاث ماذا يولد هذا
الصراع في داخلك احب ان اميل الى جانب
حدني صديق في الفيسبوك بانك حصلت على
امتيازات باج العظامه وباج اقاء المرحوم
في سن مبكر في العاش حد حدثنا عن
الامتيازات والله باج وج اصدقاء المرحوم
يعني الباجات افتخر بها اكو ملاحظه بنهايه
باج العظمه يسمح لحامل الباج بحمل ال
خاشوكه حتى اخذ را سعدت بلقائك شكرا
طق
3 2
1 يا عراق يومك هاليوم يا عراق شد حيلك
قوم
احنا ما نريد اللي يكرهنا وب ما نرضى بيوم
شح يلا
وقوم مرحبا ال استاذ شنو اشذ شن اسمك با
اسمي طارقي شن
شيه
مريض مريض
مريض شنو طزين شنو هرشا
الرشا اتمنك الموفقيه طارق بس انت ما اع
اي ص والله
مريض
خض مريض
فهم وان اعتذر ان اللجنه ما حضر اي وين
اللجنه شنا حاضرين تدكس بغداد وعافيني انا
قدمت وما قبلت ها ما قبلت فاتمنى اتمنى
تنضم لفريقي استاذ ظ يعني ما حدفني فاني
اختارك انت بشوي من بعي انا مريض انا مريض
انا مريض انا
مريض يلا
بابا الكليه
خ طف طف يلا بابا
يلا شل
بدولا خال
يلا
مرحبابك
روح روح ياذ
عليك شون
تتسمي معقول الحيا معقول بالاخير معقوله
راح
احب يا رب يا رب سهل اكي ت الرقم
اجي اليوم اشدك واخبرك على الفا
ايش
كتبتم الثلا فدوه واخيرا 77% ضربتني بوري
واخيرا عمي حت
كرش ايش
كاتبه بس بالنسبه
لجوت
where hell i'm speaking english
wc engish
حسن
do
here
my
on
my me
to the
to
my we want
to
want
what
طارق طارق اسف يا مع ل قوم قوم شاش نروح
بطني
قوم
j